LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec MGEN mutuelle santé prévoyance
présente état de santé
[Musique]
le deuil nous y avons tous été
confrontés ou nous le serons un jour une
expérience éprouvante sur tous les plans
je dors mal j'ai perdu confiance en moi
je suis extrêmement fatiguée en fait il
y a un truc il paraît que c'est
physiologique des conséquences sur la
santé physique et morale qui sont
souvent ignorées le deuil reste tabou
impensé ce mauvais accompagnement ou
cette absence d'accompagnement
la Constitution pour moi voilà un manque
de reconnaissance de ce qu'on a à vivre
alors comment mieux accompagner les
personnes endeuillées deuil comment
faire face c'est le thème de ce numéro
d'état de santé
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cet état
de santé aujourd'hui on va aborder une
question souvent tabou toujours
douloureuse souvent délicate aussi elle
concerne absolument tout le monde c'est
le deuil comment faire son deuil est-ce
que c'est une maladie le deuil par
exemple quand ça dure longtemps il y a
beaucoup de questions à vous poser
bonjour Camille vous êtes psychologue
clinicienne à la Fondation oeuvre de la
Croix Saint-Simon qui est une fondation
qui multiplie des établissements de
santé beaucoup de had comme on dit
hospitalisation à domicile je disais
dans l'introduction faire son deuil
est-ce que c'est une expression que vous
trouvez
significative qui dit des choses c'est
vrai que c'est pas forcément une
l'expression que j'emploie réelle plus
facilement mais moi je compare souvent
le deuil la mort d'un être cher à une et
c'est ce que je dis aux patient à une
blessure extrêmement profonde qui va
être très importante très profonde et le
processus de deuil se travaille de de de
cheminement qui va être propre à chacun
c'est un cheminement individuel ça va
être ce processus de cicatrisation qui
peut à peu tout doucement va se faire
c'est comme ça vous accompagner les
personnes qui sont dans le deuil depuis
quelques années on regarde votre
portrait
Camille bossant crème et psychologue
clinicienne elle consulte et encadre les
soins de support de la had à la
fondation
œuvre de la Croix Saint-Simon elle a
exercé plusieurs années auprès de
patients en fin de vie à Paris dans un
centre spécialisé puis elle a été
responsable du service d'accompagnement
du deuil au Centre national de
ressources soins palliatifs spécialiste
du deuil et de sa prise en charge elle a
également contribué à plusieurs ouvrages
scientifiques
[Musique]
vous disiez juste à l'instant donc c'est
un travail en effet fait son deuil c'est
un travail ça peut durer
quelques mois quelques années ça peut
durer très longtemps ça dépend quoi déjà
ça va dépendre de l'âge parce que quand
on est un enfant en situation deuil ça
ne sera pas la même chose que quand on
est un adulte en situation de deuil et
puis alors je pense que ça va dépendre
aussi du lien à la personne défunte ça
c'est quelque chose d'important du lien
et puis après de gérer de l'étape
psychique de chaque personne de chaque
individu ce qu'on peut considérer que il
y a des étapes
oui alors je sais qu'il y a dans la
littérature on peut voir même
différentes étapes quasiment
numérotées avec des la sidération enfin
voilà le déni la colère bon après moi
j'aime pas trop être dans des catégories
comme ça parce que je pense que les
personnes peuvent les traverser
alors les unes après les autres et puis
des fois en même temps alors ce qui se
passe quand même souvent c'est que suite
à la mort d'un être cher il y a ce temps
de sidération et ce qui se caractérise
souvent par une une phrase que les gens
disent c'est ça n'est pas possible je
c'est un cauchemar je n'y crois pas et
ça je crois que ça a vraiment ça rend
compte de l'incompréhension
psychique l'état de sidération psychique
dans laquelle la personne est donc c'est
très individuel évidemment on l'a bien
compris on vous écoutant mais il y a
quand même des points communs on va
regarder cette infographie
le deuil personne ne veut y penser et
pourtant il y a chaque année 600 000
décès en France une épreuve qui peut
être bouleversante pour les proches et
qui a des conséquences trois Français
sur cinq ont trouvé que le deuil avait
un impact sur leur santé physique et la
moitié sur leur santé psychique une
étude suédoise montrait même une
surmortalité liée au veuvage chez les
plus de 65 ans au cours des six premiers
mois du deuil et pourtant seul 20% des
endeuillers ont été prises en charge
pour leur souffrance physique ou
psychiques ils ne se sentent pas assez
épaulé
surtout au travail ou 70% des salariés
en deuil n'ont pas senti de soutien de
leur direction il faut savoir aussi que
seuls trois jours de congés d'oeil sont
attribués pour la perte d'un parent
conjoint frères ou sœurs pour un enfant
ce chiffre vient juste de passer à 15
jours
il faudrait donc mieux accompagner le
deuil et c'est aussi un enjeu de société
en moyenne on prend 34 jours d'arrêt
maladie après le décès d'un proche ce
qui représente un coup de 700 millions
d'euros annuels pour l'assurance maladie
est-ce que deuil
= dépression deuil = manifestation
dépressives c'est pas forcément une
dépression avérée une dépression qui
nécessite systématiquement un traitement
antidépresseur il peut y avoir cette
tendance un peu trop rapide des fois à
venir
mettre un anxiolytique un antidépresseur
c'est normal vous êtes en deuil paf
c'est normal vous êtes en deuil vous
pleurez voilà c'est le contraire qui
serait un peu étonnant il y a des
troubles du sommeil il y a des troubles
de la concentration il y a des troubles
de l'attention il y a des troubles voilà
de l'appétit toutes les personnes en
gris vont dire je suis épuisée parce que
psychiquement en fait voilà il y a tout
ce travail dont on parlait de qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé ça n'est pas possible
enfin la personne que j'ai que j'ai que
j'aime toujours qui n'est pas mais que
j'aime toujours ne va plus jamais être
là
plus jamais et ça c'est ça peut être un
peu abyssal vous parlez de sidération de
dépression on va tout de suite à la
rencontre via le reportage de d'Alexia
le perron justement d'une femme qui a
perdu brutalement son mari et qui nous
explique ce processus cette épreuve
qu'elle vit et comment elle essaie de la
surmonter reportage
il y a un peu plus d'un an
le compagnon de Sophie père de ses deux
enfants
décède brutalement
moi la phase de sidération elle est
passée par contre je peux pas vous dire
aujourd'hui que j'ai accepté
j'ai compris qu'il était mort accepté
non mais je dirais que c'est presque
plus difficile aujourd'hui parce qu'en
fait maintenant pour notre entourage
la page est tournée en fait c'est bon ça
y est ok c'est de l'histoire ancienne
non nous on vit le quotidien ça c'est
tous les jours pour nous et
et en fait la phase dépressive elle est
plus maintenant
plus de 8 mois après un an en
l'occurrence
c'est-à-dire c'est cette idée de
maintenant j'ai compris que il va toute
ma vie on va vivre
il ne reviendra jamais
je dors mal j'ai perdu confiance en moi
je suis extrêmement fatigué en fait il y
a un truc il paraît que c'est
physiologique
au-delà des conséquences psychologiques
le deuil
comme une dépression ça fatigue de gérer
cette idée cette absence ce silence et
toutes les réponses à formuler à ces
petits êtres
que sont nos enfants et qu'on veut
absolument
protéger dans de ce qui est encore
protégeable quoi ils ont quand même vécu
quasiment le pire à 6 ans
au fur et à mesure des jours qui
passaient après le décès je me suis
aperçue qu'il y avait
peut-être une forme d'incommunicabilité
avec mon atout mon entourage aimant
qu'il ne pouvait pas entendre certaines
choses venant de moi parce que ça allait
brusquer trop dans leur conception de
l'existence c'est trop dur pour eux
et puis il y a tous ceux qui ne
comprennent pas la réalité disent bah
c'est comme si tu étais divorcé ou
séparé non c'est pas comme parce qu'en
fait il y a plus personne il y a plus de
son il y a plus d'image
[Musique]
pour surmonter cette solitude Sophie a
décidé de rejoindre un groupe de parole
régulièrement elle se rend à
l'association empreinte pour mettre des
mots sur sa souffrance
un petit peu différent pour les uns des
autres
ont perdu leur conjoint
partage donc une douleur commune
tout le temps quand je suis avec des
amis
je vais
je pense inconsciemment c'est moi qui le
fait en premier pour pouvoir pour que ça
puisse qu'on puisse en parler
sans que eux soit gêné et que
une certaine façon moi aussi j'ai envie
d'entendre leurs souvenirs de Pascal
ça vous fait du bien nous fait du bien
de le faire vivre
les représentations de l'entourage où
ils vont surtout pas en parler
ça m'a triste
[Musique]
comme si alors que bon voilà les
émotions font partie de ce processus
c'est de telles émotions que de les
garder pour soi je pense qu'on se
détruit alors au départ on n'a peut-être
pas l'impression qu'on se détruit mais
c'est tellement dur moi je vois le
chemin
parcouru tous les jours je vois que les
choses qui tout d'un coup étaient
faciles difficiles au départ deviennent
un peu plus facile aujourd'hui donc ne
parler
permet d'exorciser finalement
les difficultés vécues le la douleur
je pense que sinon ça nous ronge à
l'intérieur à un moment donné c'est pas
un mâle qu'on soigne on prendra pas de
pilule et puis ben voilà c'est pas du
tout ça c'est une épreuve de vie qu'on
devrait d'ailleurs à rendre un petit peu
plus accessible mieux comprises par tout
le monde mais bon voilà on n'a pas trop
y penser
à la fois extrêmement intime et très
social c'est-à-dire c'est une épreuve
subjective que chaque personne
endeuillée va vivre à sa manière mais
c'est universel donc on est tous
concernés et c'est important de pouvoir
le vivre librement de façon la plus
naturelle possible puisque c'est un
processus naturel des cicatrisation
orphelin veuf et veuve par an empruntent
accompagne le deuil de chacun sans tabou
car le socialisé serait d'après
l'association la meilleure manière de le
traverser
[Musique]
Camille bossangrène est-ce qu'on voit
bien aussi dans ce reportage c'est
l'embarras de l'entourage quand on est
face à quelqu'un qui est dans cette
situation d'oeil on ne sait pas très
bien quoi faire qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire dans le fond alors ce
qu'il faut faire c'est de dire peut-être
je ne sais pas je sais que c'est
difficile je peux imaginer combien c'est
difficile pour toi comment je peux
t'aider les gens sont embarrassés ne
savent pas comment s'adresser à la
personne en deuil souvent juste après un
décès les amis la famille les gens sont
là contenants présents les premières
semaines les premiers mois ça c'est
quelque chose de très fréquent et puis
trois quatre mois après la vie a repris
son flow les gens sont repris par leur
propre activité et c'est vrai que des
fois c'est à ce moment là nous que les
personnes nous contactent ou nous
recontactent en disant bah là en fait je
me sens très seule les semaines les mois
se passent et puis le je ne le reverrai
plus jamais devient là une certitude et
c'est à ce moment là que tout le monde
dit ben maintenant tu devrais aller
mieux tu devrais plus il y a une forme
d'injonction un peu extérieur social de
fait qu'il y a un moment bon je pense
qu'il y a quelque chose à autre chose
d'ailleurs pardon mais est-ce qu'on
passe à autre chose non je le dirai pas
comme ça ça fait partie d'un voilà de
son histoire de vie ça restera toujours
je parlais de processus de cicatrisation
ça restera toujours une cicatrice
regarde la cicatrice on garde comme on
regarde la cicatrice après une opération
est-ce qu'on oublie est-ce que le deuil
c'est l'oubli non c'est le contraire de
l'oubli effectivement le deuil ce
processus cicatrisation c'est de pouvoir
mettre des mots c'est de pouvoir parler
de la personne des feintes c'est pouvoir
justement en en parlant en évoquant des
souvenirs c'est ce qui va permettre peu
à peu de mettre cette personne qu'on a
aimé qu'on aimera toujours mais à une
autre place aussi sur le plan psychique
elle fait toujours partie de ma vie mais
différemment et c'est ça se différemment
qui rencontre de ce travail de deuil
alors est-ce qu'il faudrait que
l'institution la société organise mieux
davantage l'accompagnement du deuil
d'une personne
soit un corps médical soit une
entreprise en tout cas c'est un sujet
que qui a voulu creuser Alexia le perron
pour état de santé et elle a repéré des
initiatives comme nous allons le voir
dans son reportage
le 18 février 2022
Mireille et Gilles perdent leur fille
Babette 8 ans des suites d'un cancer
rare
dans les jours qui ont suivi son décès
en termes d'institutions de que ce soit
je sais pas les hôpitaux les
assurance maladie enfin tout ce qui
existe en France autour de du soin et de
décès on a été contacté par personne
juste après le décès de Babette j'aurais
voulu effectivement être contacté alors
je sais pas par la CAF ou la caisse
primaire d'assurance maladie parce que
prendre un peu de la même chose c'est le
décès d'un enfant pour d'office nous
proposer un accompagnement psychologique
on parle pas d'une chambre cassée de
quelque chose qui va se réparer comme ça
pendant deux ans ils ont accompagné
Babette dans son combat contre le cancer
après son décès ils auraient aimé avoir
du répit
les jeunes enfants qui ont décédé c'est
souvent dans des graves maladies et donc
les familles sont déjà épuisées parce
que il y a eu tout un combat à l'hôpital
conduire auprès de leur enfant et que du
coup ben ça serait sans doute plus
souhaitable que
une fois que c'est les choses t'en
redouté finit par arriver que on vous
dise ben écoutez monsieur dame ne vous
inquiétez pas vous vous concentrez sur
votre famille votre cellule familiale
votre vos autres enfants si vous en avez
ce mauvais accompagnement ou
cette absence d'accompagnement ça
Constitution pour moi voilà un manque de
reconnaissance de ce qu'on a à vivre et
ça me laisse à dire que
institutionnellement parlant
la mort d'un enfant c'est c'est un non
événement
pour
les enfants ne meurent pas donc du coup
il y a pas d'accompagnement qui est
pensé pour ça en fait parce que c'est
impensable en fait
comme Mireille et Gilles les familles se
sont souvent livrées à elles-mêmes dans
le deuil
alors quelques structures s'organisent
pour mieux accompagner les familles
endeuillées comme cet hôpital qui a mis
en place un dispositif unique en France
bonjour madame je suis Madame Paul et je
suis assistante sociale au CHU de Nantes
je travaille sur une équipe qui vient au
soutien aux familles endeuillées
et je me permettais de vous appeler pour
prendre un petit peu de vos nouvelles
donc
à l'autre bout du fil une femme a perdu
son mari brutalement il y a quelques
jours
cet appel permet à Clémentine de lui
proposer un soutien psychologique ou
social comment ça se passe
très bien c'est de voir les différentes
formalités administratives pour être
aidé
alors nous justement on est là pour ça
si vous avez besoin madame
si ça concerne vraiment les démarches
qui sont liées au décès de votre époux
nous on peut on peut vous soutenir
là-dedans et faire le point avec vous
sur ce qui a à faire ce qui reste à
faire qu'on sait que les gens ils
traversent déjà un épisode de leur vie
qui est très très difficile et donc
l'idée c'est de rendre les choses un peu
moins compliquées en soulageant un peu
sur certaines démarches en rassurant il
y a aussi derrière l'idée de rompre
l'isolement aussi comment vous vous
sentez sur le plan du moral
même si les premiers besoins sont bien
souvent administratifs l'accompagnement
ne s'arrête pas là
le principe de dispositif c'est ça aussi
c'est signifier aux gens qui sont
importants que on se soucie d'eux et que
s'ils ont besoin on est à leur
disposition bon bah à bientôt madame
je vous en prie au revoir
ce dispositif a été à l'origine mise en
place pendant le premier confinement
pour soutenir les familles ne pouvant
pas voir leurs proches
[Musique]
composé de médecins de soins palliatifs
cadres assistantes sociales et de
psychologues cette équipe s'est
constituée dans un but
évitez les complications du deuil
bonjour tout le monde
chaque semaine elle se réunissent pour
orienter les situations les plus à
risque
il y a vraiment ces questions un peu de
difficultés financières elle dit aussi
que c'est jamais elle qui s'est occupée
de ça du coup c'est son mari là pour
cette situation je vais peut-être je
vais l'appeler pour voir si elle est
d'accord et puis je vais peut-être lui
proposer un accompagnement avec une
assistante sociale de secteur parce que
là c'est quand même enfin il va y avoir
besoin d'un gros accompagnement quand
même on est un peu le premier guichet
auxquels sont confrontés les familles et
en fonction des besoins on va orienter
vers tous les partenaires du secteur que
ça soit au niveau social on les oriente
beaucoup vers la CAF au niveau
psychologique aussi on peut faire du
lien avec les acteurs quand on est
frappé par le deuil et d'autant plus si
c'est un décès qui survient de manière
hydatue en fait on est complètement
perdu et on n'a pas du tout les
ressources pour aller chercher ce qui
existe près de chez soi on sait même
souvent pas ce dont on a besoin l'équipe
du CHU tente à présent d'étendre son
dispositif à d'autres familles les
initiatives comme celle-ci sont encore
trop rares en France et inégalement
répartie sur le territoire
alors c'était intéressant dans le
reportage d'Alexia c'est structure
nantaise qui accompagne qui en est qui
en tant qu'institution accompagne les
personnes les appels fait des démarches
vous avez travaillé dans des structures
de soins palliatifs est-ce que vous avez
la possibilité comme ça proposait ce
type d'accompagnement aux proches des
malades que vous aviez suivi avant en
fait ça n'est pas pris en compte du tout
dans dans
le soin dans la présence enfin une fois
que le patient est décédé il est décédé
et c'est la la position de la volonté de
l'établissement qui a ses propres frais
va dire on continue à proposer cette
offre de soins de soins psychiques pour
pouvoir justement continuer à
accompagner les personnes les proches
vous l'avez fait et voilà et on le fait
régulièrement
on le fait systématique on le propose
systématiquement est-ce qu'il y a des
deuils pathologiques est-ce qu'il y a
des deuils dont on ne sort jamais alors
il peut y avoir des deuils path logique
des deuils pathologiques considérés
comme tel voilà j'appelle pathologique
le fait qu'on n'en sort jamais mais
psychopathologique particulière et
bruyante et qui va être finalement à la
marge ce qui peut y avoir par contre de
plus fréquent ce sont des deuils qui
seront comme gelées en fait qui ne vont
pas pouvoir s'élaborer comme s'il va y
avoir une espèce de gel de du processus
de deuil et que justement quand il y a
un accompagnement qui est proposé ça
peut permettre ce ce processus alors il
faut parler aussi du deuil en entreprise
parce que quand on a un deuil on a droit
du jour de congé et puis c'est tout
est-ce qu'il faudrait aller au delà ce
qu'il faudrait qu'il y ait un
accompagnement sur cette question nous
sommes allés interroger la députée
Renaissance Michel perron qui avait
justement travaillé sur ces questions
participer à une proposition de loi pour
mieux accompagner les personnes en
deuyées est-ce qu'on pourrait par
exemple rendre obligatoire un dispositif
d'accompagnement
du deuil dans toutes les entreprises on
lui a posé la question voici sa réponse
la gestion humaine du deuil est
particulière donc il leur faudrait un
référent une personne habilité qui a
reçu une formation alors pour les
entreprises de d'importance qu'il y a un
référent par entreprise ceci s'entend
mais pour les PME pour les TPE un
référent commun ça peut se faire mais il
faut évidemment que cette personne ait
reçu une formation je souhaite et mes
collègues qui étaient signataires avec
moi de donc de la PPL de serenbaumorde
souhaite évidemment que cela soit
obligatoire et que cela passe par la loi
est-ce que l'idée effectivement que dans
chaque entreprise il y a une personne de
la direction des RH des relations
humaines qui soient formées pour
accompagner un salarié c'est une bonne
idée ça sera pas cette personne
ressource qui va s'occuper de tous mais
qui peut justement de par la qualité de
son écoute et la connaissance des
dispositifs peut aussi orienter la
personne et ça je pense que c'est ça qui
peut être intéressant que du coup
justement il est pas cette ce silence
autour du deuil et enfin pour conclure
est-ce que c'est un enjeu de santé
publique est-ce que il faudrait des
prises en charge plus importante
après la mort consubie je pense qu'il
s'agit pas de médicaliser ni de
psychologie parce que ça n'est pas
forcément une nécessité toutes les
actions que mène certaines associations
en proposant ces espaces de parole
d'accompagnement de partage ça permet
justement de travailler collaboration du
deuil et c'est des lieux ressources
extrêmement précieux pour les personnes
après quel moyen donner aussi à ces
dispositifs c'est là où peut-être l'État
pourrait soutenir voilà aussi bien comme
les expériences là de sur Nantes ou sur
les autres structures les rendre plus
visibles plus visibles les aider qui est
une plus grande reconnaissance et un
soutien qui passe aussi par un soutien
financier voilà je retiens en tout cas
de cette émission aussi que face à
quelqu'un qui est en deuil il faut pas
avoir peur d'en parler ouais il faut
verbaliser il faut pas avoir peur de
mettre le sujet parce que de dire
comment elle a besoin aussi d'évoquer ce
qui lui manque la personne qui lui
manque et donc bon ça serait peut-être
pas toujours le moment mais c'est
important de ne pas faire comme si ça
n'existe pas est-ce qu'on prend parfois
on veut ménager exactement on veut
ménager où on se sent tellement en
difficulté et de dire tout simplement
j'imagine quelle est ta en France
combien ça peut être difficile je suis
là je sais pas comment je pourrais
t'aider qu'est-ce qui peut te faire du
bien mais je suis là je suis là merci
beaucoup de nous avoir fait partager
votre expérience autour du deuil merci
de nous avoir suivis et à bientôt sur
état de santé sur LCP
[Musique]
LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec mgeen mutuelle santé prévoyance
vous a présenté état de santé
[Musique]